how are you guys doing i want to share
something with you the message is
powerful
for those who would reflect
and i want you to listen reflect ponder
over these words
and if they were coming from
your average person it'd be one thing
but it's coming from someone who
most of the world knows by now
so habib is saying it's been a year
today since the father's gone his father
passed longer than a year ago but pay
attention to the message
it's been a year today since the
father's gone this event has increased
my belief that in this world we own
nothing
not our children
not our parents
not our property
everything we have is temporary
all things belong to allah let me stop
there allah simply means for the people
hearing this word for the first time or
they don't know what it means it simply
means the creator of the heavens and the
earth god almighty allah the same god
that jesus moses abraham and the last
and final messenger problem muhammad
peace be upon them all they call people
to worship he is one and alone worthy of
worship this is the crate of the heavens
and earth jews and christians who are
arabic speaking they also use the word
allah for god
all things belong to allah alone and to
him we shall return
tie your hearts to allah stay more alone
with him
for a time will come when we will all be
put in the grave
where we will be alone
where our friends relatives property and
connections
will not be there
only our deeds and report
very powerful i wanted to share that
with you guys
like i said
this is
for those who will reflect those who
will ponder take a minute
or two or three
and ask the creator the heavens and
earth for guidance
you haven't figured out the purpose of
life why
a person will live 72 years like i had
somebody the other day and i asked him i
said
you've been here a very long time can
you share with me have you ever
thought about the purpose of life have
you figured it out the man said kindly
he said no i haven't so most people are
not taking the matter serious
and who best to ask
than the one who created creation the
creator of the heavens and earth god
almighty allah say the one who created
me guide me and then look into islam
look into islam submission to the
creator not the creation that's what it
simply means and a muslim is one who has
submitted his or her will to the one and
only god almighty allah like habib has
and then you live a life
that's pleasing to your creator before
you meet your creator and then put this
in
to perspective the grave
leaving all your friends and your family
and property
in reality owning nothing
because it's all going to stay behind
and what are you taking with you
you can't take those ufc belts
they're all going to be left behind with
that money the cars
and everything with it
so
this is deep think about it share it
with someone friends and family or
somebody who's just
needing a quick
reminder of the day we'll see you next
time peace be with you